where is it oh this one is nice
i'm not sure if i've seen this exact
theme
all right
it's funny that every kind of mage has
its own name
i i i could never i could never think
about it okay queen
ea [ __ ] of c5
learning something new every day
here i think you just go for another one
see i wonder if there is
uh
an uh
a position from my game here i guess i
think i had a couple of minutes there
queenie one or two knight of one
probably each
handgun
okay just queenish two queen two okay
oh this is this is a weird puzzle
because clearly although we're a piece
down there are a million ways to win
here
but yeah you gotta exchange first then
okay
damiano okay this is damiano almost
fabiano mage
but this is damiano okay
here night mates
okay
well i think i got it nice
and then here's three
g4 next one
all right so probably give you a check
and then something happens in the very
end okay let's give a check
let's give another check
let's get another check ah that's pretty
one can be three and then g4 on the next
one okay i like it
rookie three
this has got to be brute force
yeah i think this is brute force
queen d3 and now h5
right yeah h5 is the one
it was that five
ah annoying annoying i didn't say this
so here probably rookie three should be
uh should be enough queen d3
well it's running
was kind of unexpected
probably i should take
probably okay i like a five
and here okay okay nice one
nice one
okay it's gotta be rook to e1 first so
you don't have to actually calculate it
[ __ ] page six
there's nothing i can do i think
no i don't think so
alternative okay
both
both are obviously made
this looks
like a piece of cake actually
so maybe just rookie one it takes
through k8
here i should pick the move like a
bishop bishop h6 probably no i mean okay
there king can never escape here
and there is no nobody check
kicking each one
caffeine another rook of eight all right
queen g7 standard stuff
okay
this one is lovely
or 97 as well
oh so you go to d7 this one is nice yeah
d7 to cut off the king
and then you go knight h7
f6
uh well this is all next lesson okay
probably d7
790 okay
probably this one is magic
since this is a puzzle i think this has
got to be
it's got to be brute force
but where is the mate there
rookie seven takes takes everything
oh they just want uh okay
this is so dull though
just a completely standard smothered
mate
okay alright
so what do we do now probably
if we take another queen system he plays
king of six and runs
so maybe something besides this
uh that's a good question actually okay
any move was winning side i don't like
this puzzle i don't really like this
puzzle so there is e7 as well
what if i just play e7
and queen c4
i mean okay
i don't think there's any mates after
rook h5 so i gotta take him g6
so should i go richie's
no i should check first i think
wait a sec
it's gotta be
rook h3 at some point
it's very slightly tricky this one
oh
no that was incorrect
get it
oh it's this one okay okay okay okay
all right so
there is there are very few moves here
okay this like that doesn't count
and it's just out of play
forever
so maybe we should just take on g6 and
then just
triple our forces here
yeah all right
this is this is correct maybe just rook
h3 and then
i wonder what's better here
different h3 he plays for example queen
h7
what do i do then
this is maybe a little bit wrong
ah i can just deliver matrix checks
that's fine
that's just pretty fine